look at this look come on how you
feeling this you know I'm just so happy
to be here she's humble I'm good she's
great well you're looking like a baddie
you look so awesome how did you like
settle on this look for the amas tonight
well you know I wanted to do a full look
tonight so I want to give some Marc
Jacob this look was very like spicy
still fun but still elegant so I thought
it was perfect for famous it was the
first piece that you were like I'm gonna
rock this and then kind of built the
rest of the look around okay well it's a
full look so it was already built oh it
was good it was already okay from the
runway yeah no I got the full look and
then from there I probably added you
know the little touches like the makeup
some fun hair the Amy's is a party
because there's almost everyone in music
is here across genre who are you excited
to see tonight you know what I'm excited
to see Anita I'm excited to you know
Bebe rexa I love that song
um
she's extending the summer with that one
that's for sure honestly um I need to
talk about music with you what is
inspiring uh you as you're kind of
preparing and working on this next
record you know
I'm fun and people can dance too but
also kind of experimenting with you know
some of my r b tones and Melodies and
kind of combating those with like some
interesting tempos it should be fun you
know tonight they are acknowledging the
passing of takeoff and I know that you
had said he was your favorite Migos
member how will you remember take off
you know I think take off is such an
amazing talent and I think he's going to
go down in history as somebody who
really set the Mark I think the Migos
was such a legendary group and I'm just
honestly
still very very very very sad about the
entire how it all played out and I think
that we're
you know we're really missing one of our
generational figures I think that he
went way too soon 28 so young so it's
definitely a tragedy and I think you
know his music is going to go down in
history on the test of times big fan so
we are going to miss him aren't we
definitely